- Mark, I'm pretty convinced
that I need to protect my
devices from other folks.
How should I think about that?
How does one protect their device?
- Yeah.
The first piece is really
taking what the manufacturers
and the companies behind
them are giving you.
So, when you receive this notice that,
you know, your phone is ready
to get a security update
or ready to get a patch,
it's really important to do that ASAP.
The reason is that, once
that alert shows up,
the attackers basically
know about a vulnerability.
So it's kind of like if somebody says,
you know, on allowed speaker,
"Hey, your front door is unlocked."
Like, the longer you wait,
the more chance for someone to come in.
So, I know it can be annoying,
you're in the middle of a meeting,
you're running for a taxi, what have you,
but the sooner that you do that,
the better you are protected.
On Google devices, on Android phones,
on our pixel phones,
we push these out
and try to make it so
it's as easy as possible.
So there are very few steps,
very few things for you to worry about.
It will take a few minutes,
it will use some wifi data,
but that's probably the
first and best recommendation
I'd give.
- That's a really interesting point
because I think all of us, sometimes
whatever device we're using
from whichever manufacturer,
they always say, oh,
would you like to update?
You know, and all this.
And we're like, oh, I'm busy.
I don't wanna restart
things, et cetera, et cetera.
But to your point, it's not just about,
oh, there's been some shady behavior
that's already occurred
and this protects you,
but it's a big beacon to say,
hey, in case you didn't
notice shady folks,
these are ways that you might.
So that's a really good time to update.
What other things should I watch out for?
- One of them is to only install
apps from trusted sources.
So, on your iPhone, it
comes from the App Store,
on your Google Android phone,
it comes from the Play Store.
We test these on a continuous basis.
The Google Play Protect
scans billions of applications
and is continually updating
to ensure that you're only getting
things that have been vetted
and that have gone through scanning.
But if you're trying to
get something for nothing,
or, you know, often is the case,
your kids are trying to
get something for nothing
and they find a free version of a game
that's in some, you know,
dodgy corner of the web,
this is kind of like
going down a dark alley
and, you know, buying stuff from somebody
with a trench coat on.
You get what you pay for
and what that might include
is viruses, malware,
and hacking threats.
- No, no, I agree so much with that
because sometimes I've
looked for like, even a patch
from a well known, you know,
from some piece of software that comes.
And I do it and some of
these shady actors actually
have search results that are pretty high
that they might be a paid
ad or something like that.
And I'm not sure whether
they're necessarily
but you realize that the person
claiming to provide a patch
for a certain piece of software
isn't necessarily the
publisher of that software.
So I'm not saying necessarily
that those are good or bad actors,
but it is vary to your point,
be extra careful you're
installing anything
on a any kind of device
who it's coming from.
- We built something at Google
called the Security Checkup
really designed to be this one stop shop
for all your devices,
everything you've got
connected to your account.
So there's a simple link
g.co/security checkup.
And what that does is it runs through
is your device protected
against local threats,
you know, somebody grabbing it and just,
you know , surfing your data,
is it protected against online hacking,
are you up to date with
patches and security issues,
are you installing, you know,
apps from safe locations.
Basically all the tips
that I would give somebody
bundled together into this one stop shop,
g.co/security checkup.